I could see pushing this room out and
then bending this hallway making a
little bit more interesting than this
sort of if you can basically do a little
bit of people straight game playing out
here especially with the minigun the
biggest thing that we're really zeroing
in on is the movement mechanics and how
we move through the world that's where
we focus most of our time the weapons
are coming online which are really great
and I mean the sniper rifles finally
someone usable so it's been it's been a
good set of changes the biggest changes
in heaven being all the weapons it was a
mere people were laughing at us because
we were so excited to be playing and it
was a square box you know it was a room
with two boxes in it we were jumping
around accusing Nick of cheating we're
getting getting up on the ledges cheater
hack now we only have two weapons we had
an okay shot by fooling we have a game
now all right let the pain begin what's
really exciting me now is that we
started doing daily play tests and the
game is really fun to play and so we're
really going through and playing and
every day our feedback is really more
about you know how can we make this
better how can we tweak this value and
there's just lots to do to keep making
the game better and better and so that's
a lot of fun when you get to that point
oh we definitely need team-colored
shield belt anytime I see a shield I
have no idea it's my team or not
oh we need a teammate
names over their heads too
I really want to know that I gotten
assist and I lay on most of the hit
points and then I just want to say that
was pretty much all you bro
and we've implemented pretty much all of
the weapons so far some of them in
blueprints some of them are in C++ we
have a couple of really cool levels and
we have DM working my Ultra killed it
don't run away at least I didn't see all
the changes that are happening with the
weapons movement that the levels are
community ourselves lots of cool stuff
to see